welcome to this video when Noah do I we
are doing ok that's a new opponent I
never played him or her for that matter
you never know ok we got a wii with d3
ok better be careful the apple should be
seven just drops at porn so what now I
can go g6 on this position I guess or is
he going for the lady for maybe start
with that so I got the early fianchetto
in that normally is slide accomplishment
for black because you often go for the
vehicle by yeah by slower means Bishop
e7 Rukia hate then back to f8 and so on
okay night h5 is a possibility here not
sure about it to be honest
I'm not sure about this 9h 5 it's got
Bishop g5 for example and I don't really
I don't want to go have 64 for instance
that doesn't look right so I'm going for
playing the center trying to get in t-5
if possible okay so hmm yeah but should
be 6 that is essentially transposing to
some kind of italian game but it's not a
bad idea i think if he trades I mean
this is not very ambitious for white if
he trades and the ship c2 there's d5 and
I'm ready for d5 anyway so quite often a
good rule of thumb in the double king
porn opening this if Black gets in d5
without any particular concession then
he normally is fine and it looks like
the fibers is possible here so let's do
it d 5
yep just develops now of course I can
just take let's say and play this
position that's a bit too bit dull
I think I can keep that tension in the
center there is no particular need to
take and I have Queen d7 roop the eight
moves like that so let's go for that the
only thing he might have deformed at
some point no but that looks that looks
unlikely I mean looks unlikely that it
is netting him much so it's just going
back here
OOP 2d6 maybe it's a bit of a strange
move but I don't I don't see a drawback
and I'm threatening to take on you for
now tripling behind that d 5 point is an
uncommon uncommon sight but I don't see
what's wrong with it
now I don't see what's wrong with it if
it takes it our can take with the root
level and then d3 is under enormous
pressure
not so easy to adjust to a suggest a
movie of a wide something that looks
fully satisfactory yeah i was thinking
about stuff like that but that looks
quite an artificial not CLE however if i
can exploit it would be nice to get in
something like Bishop h6 but i don't
know yeah maybe h5 I mean 95 Kings yet I
don't mind yeah okay
to bishop age six that's the deal here
I'm not taking so that you can take with
the rukon see one I want the rukon d1 so
that there is really a pin a pin going
on so okay can take you can check with
the rook here
you have to take that anyway and now so
Luke t3 and everything gets taken at the
end he's got roped xe5 that's quite
unfortunate and I takes you five at the
end hmm the end then yeah there's just a
draw unfortunately hmm can I do more
here I mean something like f6 looks a
bit wrong okay I think I'm grabbing this
if it's a draw okay it's a draw
so luke t 323 rope d3 Bishop age 6 King
takes 90 x + 5 and wonder if there is
something else that I can do some
intermediate move doesn't look very
promising so let's take here yeah time
money was just a draw check let's give
that chick yeah I can go here rookie to
my plate before I ok let's let's do this
is the simplest draw
DRA offered locates trying because of
the time
yeah it's not much not much going on
quite clearly check
can just hope for me check with a clock
here that's an interesting idea doesn't
let anything at the end but check you at
least tried something check no I'm ahead
on channel channel pornog
check check check hey check ins and a
long time and don't position plenty for
fence on time yeah I should have taken
the draw yes um as long as he had the
opportunity yeah but soon they want to
win on time and to try think that don't
work yeah the question is can I could
have done more here somewhere around
here i think we are talking about a
pretty equal position i'm happy to have
d 50 it's interesting out rippling up
here now look you to that looks like
that looks kind of unnatural that move
but it's um it's difficult to just to
suggest anything i am interesting like
the engine is very clever here and i
went here which is not bad but computer
to this this is a bit more subtle
because you're pretty to prepare that
yeah and you're not running into a
possible check that's a that's a good
choice it's a little bit a little bit
better than what I did okie abortion h6
yeah and now so this isn't it better
Weiss is why am I not the engine is
giving me a clear edge and they don't
understand why
hmm check f5 that move I did not
consider five the idea is that this pawn
is just moving away from being attacked
so that after Luke here there is no
threat against f7 anymore see and this
means that this double attack is where
something so that was that was a clearly
better way to do it the engine gives
this with a clear pawn now what is
drawing shots of course Talmud this is
what I should have done now I didn't see
that I saw I saw a five but I didn't
really understand understand that this
is removes the f palm from the attack
from the Lucani seven ok and here this
is just going for the draw yeah I could
have done this but I wasn't sure I he
actually I thought what I you know
whatever look that I can take care ha I
thought I have to go here and then
before wasn't clear at all to me because
he's threatening to take both and this
is actually actually equal so Luke takes
f to this is the thing I didn't see that
one this is this is not looking good for
wide yeah that was the way for an
advantage him yeah rooty to again was
possible but I just wanted to play it
safe and play quick moves while doing it
check yeah try that at age five that
Rosa needs to try but it still it's a
remain she commands constantly draw this
this
ELC five is a draw and still see five
yeah it's a draw for why the king is
closed and he can always go see if I but
check he never did somehow check check
yeah yeah channel from here so it's
losing okay hmm ticking is actually a
draw according to the engineer rugby 5s
winning okay I had 11 seconds so I'm not
kind of surprised that this is a draw
look H was what the engine gives you our
kids difficult i can with Raquel with a
king hmm ok check and she's also draw I
suspected that much with the King Sonya
it will be ever be a draw but okay I was
winning on time and he was the one
trying for the time with in the first
place so I don't mind and Esther can try
to win this position even though it's a
draw I've got the the pawn to play for
okay well thanks for watching